-Well, finally, guys, since today is 4/20,
I actually...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I actually wrote a song to celebrate the holiday.
But then I realized, you know what?
Kids watch this show, and I got to set a good example.
So I changed the song to be about Earth Day instead.
And you could barely notice the difference in the lyrics.
Let's do this.
Roots, can you give me a little tune?
What's a good song?
[ Reggae music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ It's a glorious day, so I'll sing you a song ♪
♪ But first you've got to sit down ♪
♪ And light up your... LED light bulbs ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Sit in a circle and try not to choke ♪
♪ As the room fills up with a whole bunch of... ♪
Reusable tote bags.
[ Laughter ]
♪ The room's gettin' hot, kind of feels like a sauna ♪
♪ That's on the account of dank carbon emissions ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Now, if you're feeling buzzed, I'm not talking mosquitoes ♪
♪ You want to eat a large bag of cool ranch... ♪
Organic seaweed crisps.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Let me wrap things up, here's my final point ♪
♪ We should all get together and light a... ♪
Sign that says "Save the Earth."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it's better.
We have a great show!